hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for
Monday November 13th
2023 what's going on how are you how's
it going you like the new
microphone Crystal Clear ignorance
coming at you to start the work week
sorry I'm late I uh had to fly back I'm
finally back home my last long run of
the year that's it all I got is Vegas
next weekend one [__] quick
um one quick gig and that that's it
that's it and then I'm done for the
whole year and I got nothing else I got
nothing lined up I ain't doing [__] okay
I ain't doing [__] [__] um that's my
game plan my game
plan is I'm not doing [__] um first of
all I can talk about old dads now the
strike is
over strike is over you know we didn't
lose too bad right it's only for three
years each each every three years now
they're going to do more and more AI
until they lose until they just get rid
of [__] everybody that's that's what
I think they're going to start with
extras and then they're going to move to
character actors and then leads and then
directors I think they're just going to
gradually do that but what's great is
they're going to act like AI is for
everybody and how they going to do that
is they going to give regular people
robots that they can [__] any way that
they want right and then this is you
know I don't think it's all bad it's
convenient it helps me with my
groceries [__] blows me I like it and
then meanwhile there's going to be like
a [__] switch in
there um and they're just going to take
all of us out you're going to have it in
you're going to invite the [__] devil
into your [__] house oh Jesus Bill
what happened I thought you were all
excited that your goddamn week was your
your travel was done for the
year
um yes very happy about that I had an
amazing amazing amazing weekend I uh and
the rest of the week I'm trying to think
I know I did the Thursday podcast I
don't know if I talked to you about the
Atlanta show I did the Atlanta show I
had a great [__] time hung out with
this great cigar bar right next to the
Tabernacle and then uh I went and I did
the
show and just killing just having a
great time my buddy Todd paraca came
down billionaire Boogeyman right he came
in he did some time Dean Del re [__]
killed it and I went
up I was just [__] perfect I was
killing everything's going great I'm
going into my last bit
you know get ready to smile and wave and
get out of there and all of a sudden
everybody starts yelling up pointing at
this
person and I'm thinking like what am I
talking about that has to do with this
person I guess somebody in the crowd had
some sort of medical
episode um I think it was a seizure or
something but uh they said they they end
when they got to him they ended up like
walking him out her out I think it was a
woman under her own power she kind of
had her head down and was embarrassed
which is much as it sucks to be
embarrassed it's also a good thing that
you're feeling the emotion of
embarrassed so that sounds like the
person was all right which was a
relief uh I'm not going to lie to you it
was definitely uh you know had to figure
out how to get out of that like keep the
show going as everybody's rubbernecking
looking at this person so um from what I
heard they were okay so that's a good
thing um and then the next night I went
down to uh Hollywood
Florida and did the casino down there
the one that looks like a Les Paul
guitar and uh just had this incredible
[__]
view I could see all the way down to
Miami Fort
Lauderdale and all of that and it was
you know I could see you know some of
the really I love the architecture in uh
in Miami I just I don't know what it is
that art deco and then there sort of the
lines you know that a lot of them had
like that s sort of shape to him very
unique um I don't know enough about it
to talk intelligently about it but that
is this
podcast
um so that show ended up being great too
and then me Dean and Kenny flew up to
New York City and um I did Madison
Square Garden and it was funny like
people were going are you nervous are
you nervous and I was like no I'm not
I'm not but what I was trying not to do
is be thinking thinking I was kind of
thinking like you know what I do an hour
and 15 minutes I say [__] good night
and then I am on vacation that's what I
was looking at as I was going in there
and I'm like that's not the right
attitude to have Bill you need to give
these people a show but of course once
you go into the venue you [__] your
nerves get going and everything and um I
had uh this one comedian open up that I
saw on Instagram I thought was funny uh
uh Leah Samson she went up she killed it
then she brought up Josh adamaya and
then Dean Del re I brought the two rock
and roll comedians made sense and then
the special surprise guest if you follow
me on Instagram you know who it was the
one and only Andrew Dice Clay and he
went up there and was just [__]
murdering to the point I was backstage
going like why the [__] did I do that
you
know I I should be on stage right now
and he's just going to wear this [__]
crowd out you know even though he's only
doing in 10 minutes he's [__] dice
right and this is his house basically so
and then sagora was hanging side stage
you know sagor is a [__] beast I'm
like ah [__] he's GNA see my new [__] I
hope I'm funny you know blah blah blah
right a little bit of pressure there and
then dice just gave me the greatest
intro and um gave me a big bear hug was
unbelievable it was unbelievable I got
to play m Square Garden with Andrew dce
Clay if you told 21-year-old me way back
in
1989 when I was watching The Dice Man
that I would ever even become a comedian
forget about work with him and do it at
Madison Square Garden and he was going
to say all these nice things about my
comedy it was [__] amazing so thank
you to him thank you to everybody that
came
out um it was such a great
crowd um and you know I've been doing
these bigger venues so I didn't have to
adjust I just felt totally ready for it
and it just it was perfect came down
there earlier played drums they had the
drums miked up and [__] it was [__]
ridiculous my life is this weekend has
just been this whole week has been
ridiculous and then the next
night you know oh then we had the
Afterparty at Gotham Comedy Club you
know Steve missil thanks to everybody
down there and everybody came down they
had the Cake Boss make a cake and all of
that [__] and I all of my friends were
down there like everyone from people
I've known for like a year to like
people that I started out with like 31
years ago so that was amazing and um and
then the next night I went back to
Madison Square Garden with the lovely
Nia and uh we got to [__]
uh go to the UFC sitting right down
[__] low
like front basically there's one row you
know the Joe Rogan row I'll call it that
the announcers row and then there's a
space and then um the first row so we
were like right there I'll be honest
with you I was [__] nervous I was
like you know I watched this violence
like on uh on TV you know there's a
separation this is going to be like
right in front of me watching some of
the greatest athletes in the world just
beating the [__] out of each other am I
going to be able to handle
this um you know you never know so I
ended up going down there and uh we
sitting down
there and I don't know why but for some
reason being there you can see the
adjustments Fighters are making a lot
easier than on TV I don't know it's
because you're just sitting there
watching it and you're not sort of like
dealing with the the director editing
and sort of you can kind of just and
what I kind of I don't know any of the
fighters names so don't even [__]
start with me I'm too busy to to follow
the sport the way I need to uh I do love
it I just don't have time
so I kind of noticed with like fights it
was like they were all everybody was so
[__] good that night that it was like
whoever figured the other person out
first won the fight and like and I felt
like all of them did it like a half a
second before the other person figured
them
out um especially on like that last
fight cuz I was just looking at the
those two fighters the dude in the
yellow and then the dude in the red
right and I was watching it and I'm
looking at the dude in the yellow I'm
like that guy looks like he means
business the other guy looked like he
wasn't in quite a good of shape so I
said I think maybe the guy in the
yellow's going to win this right then
the guy in the red comes out and he's
got this weird little [__] like faint
that he would do he just didn't know
what was going to happen he like LED
with an uppercut and it landed and I was
like oh he's one of these guys the weird
angle
guys all right let's see what [__]
happens and the yellow guy started
coming back no no yellow guy's going to
win the [__] red guy comes back and
then all of a sudden the guy in the
yellow G the old right there Fred with a
couple of [__] elbows caught him um
that was to end the night but like
um I I I can't even tell you how what a
different experience it is watching
it that close it was [__] amazing it
was amazing the only thing was annoying
me was in between fights all the [__]
walking around and people talking and
glad handed
no one was talking about the
fights was a lot of that pointing and
all that Hollywood [__] hey [__] you
there you are and you know you know
what's [__] hilarious is when two
straight guys go to hug there's always
that pause before the the tents up and
then the
[__] really hard slaps on the
back um type of [__] all of that [__]
that was going on in between
um it was weird I mean NE we just sort
of was sitting there talking about the
fights and
uh and then it was also cool watching
when Joe gets up Rogan gets up to go
in you know to interview the fighters
and stuff because I was like watching
him calling the fights too and
uh like that is not I I knew it wasn't
an easy job but watching all the
movement that that guy has to do and
then come back sit down and then get
going and start talking about the next
one that is not a uh he makes look easy
but it it was
uh whatever I don't know you know it's
always cool when you see something like
a million [__] times on TV then you
actually go to it you're like you can't
believe you're there so
uh I don't know I kind of liked all the
decisions except for one I thought that
baby baby shark I thought she won that
fight and I was looking at the other
fight I'm like she's got a big bruise
under her eye and she's her nose is all
messed up and the other one looked like
other than her braid was a little [__]
up that's like that was a split decision
or whatever other than that I thought
everything was
cool um so anyway thanks to Dana and
everybody at the UFC for hooking us up
we had a
[__] we had a great time and I went
there with the veries you know and club
soda Kenny and uh you know was Paul's
birthday I forgot that we did that
beforehand we like do we smoke a cigar
before we get like no no let's get over
there get to the [__] fights um it
was really really cool so whatever all
I'm doing is just telling you what I did
this [__] week I'm not even talking
could [__] try and make you laugh at
some point right I guess I did a little
bit the [__] bro hugging I did enjoy
all that bro hugging and stuff because
like you know they always talk I can't
live out and I can't live out in [__]
uh La man it's just too [__] phony I
got to be honest with you dude I haven't
seen phony
at that level those in between [__]
fights schmoozing the [__] schmoozing
that's going on is on at like a
Hollywood award show [__] level dude
it was
like hey
[Laughter]
bro uh it was an embarrassment of human
behavior but other than that other than
that the [__] fights were great and
all all of that uh all of that [__] it
was also kind of cool to be uh
come back to the Garden like the very
next night after doing a show there and
looking around being like this looks
totally [__] different totally
[__] different and I don't have any
pressure I can just [__] sit here and
[__] enjoy it and get [__] up but I
don't get [__] up anymore so that's
the only part that sucked however what I
did do is um I've had like nine coffees
today so don't don't get on me about
being all [__] amped up here I'm also
excited cuz I haven't seen my kids yet
they're coming home in a second
um I [__]
uh hung around
Sunday and um we went out to Brooklyn
they wanted to go to that Jay-Z exhibit
that was like one of the last days went
out there you know really cool anytime
you see like like a self-made man you
know telling the story it's always good
that's like I heard Stallone's
documentaries [__] amazing like
Schwarzenegger I put it into that
Schwarzenegger Stallone Jay-Z all of
that like you know they said we couldn't
do it and then we [__] did that whole
thing it's just you get all amped up
like looking at [__] like that and
um really cool exhibit if you get a
chance they had like they sort of
rebuilt his studio in one place um that
kind of matched the photos on the wall I
like that and then there was also a
great picture of him in like it looked
like a late 90s or early 2000
Mercedes like Jay-Z very on on on very
quietly has really great taste in cars I
saw him one time he had a Porsche that
was like silver and it was really clean
it wasn't it was just you knew it was
like one of the top ones but like I'm
I'm not a big Porsche guy but he he
didn't have all this hey look at me [__]
on it it was just a f it was like James
Bond sort of done up man it was [__]
really cool um but anyway old Billy fat
tits so you
know I got a little b a break here so
I'm sitting there thinking like all
right I'm going to go uh I'm going to
[__] go um I'm going to go to the gym
hit the gym when I get back so I can be
a little bad here so we went to this
famous um ice cream and candy place on
the uh Lower East Side we come walking
in and I see this an egg cream I've
always wondered about that CU it always
sound gross to me like there was like a
[__] raw egg in there or something I
go I go what's an egg cream the gu's
like you don't know what egg cream is I
said no I go let me try one of those
like cuz most people get like a black
and white want so I said all right I
don't no egg ever went in there so I
don't know what where how why it's
called an egg cream it was a couple of
shots some syrup and then some milk and
then they just stirred it up to like a
froth and I drank it and I got to tell
you something man it was out of this
[__]
world so now I'm just like all
right I got to try and forget that
because that's something that I'm going
to going to [__] up and try and recreate
out here which you can't do
you know what I mean it's like this
morning I'm at Newark [__] airport
and I got a burrito I'm on my way to La
I'm in New Jersey and I order a burrito
like what the [__] am I thinking you
know total heartburn right stupid and
now I'm out here in La I'm all [__]
up I'm out here in La after I got a
burrito in New Jersey and I'm out here
in Los Angeles thinking about an egg
cream stupid so I I got to get my I got
to get my [__] head right here um
anyway let's talk football
[Music]
what um the only game I had time to
watch was I unfortunately you know I was
in New York I didn't have the NFL
package or whatever the [__] it is the
YouTube stupid [__] and
um I watched the the
Giants Cowboys game oh my God just the
absolute drubbing and of course you know
they're not going to shut the game off
it's like [__] 21 nothing
28-6 for the half or something and
they're just not going to shut it off
cuz it's in the Giants market so I just
sort of had that game on um I watched
the highlights of the
Patriots game which was which was my
lock of the week I did pick the
Browns against the Ravens but I also um
took Joe
burrow I had the Lions I had the Browns
those are my wins for the week and then
I had the Patriots that was was my hat
stupid and then um Joe burrow up against
those goddamn Texans I'm telling you
right now dude if you're a gambling
person if I'm not going to say a
degenerate if you're a Gambling Man or
gambling woman the [__] Texans
cover they like low-key [__] cover
and they're winning games that they
shouldn't be winning so I'm sure this
week everybody's going to jump on them
so the [__] lines are going to come
down or whatever um also Celtics Knicks
tonight I'm going to check that out cuz
I've just been trying to watch the
Bruins and everybody that's you know is
a Celtics fan in my life just keeps
telling me you know how [__] amazing
the
uh [__] amazing the Celtics are or
whatever but
um anyway I'm all over the map here I I
uh I apologize I'm trying to think of
anything you know I just did a bunch of
work I'm trying to think if anything
funny happened to me a woman had an
epileptic seizure that's not funny
it was in the middle of me doing a bit
talking about rape how about that is
that funny because it
wasn't it wasn't what I was doing it I
was like ah Jesus
Christ I thought it cuz I just made fun
of somebody fat I was I thought it was
somebody fat in the crowd I'm like is
this the fat person from my story in the
crowd is that why they yelling I had no
idea what the [__] was going on
um
anyway I don't know probably the
funniest [__] I saw was was the Bros
around
uh ringside you know then there's it's
always great when you go to a fight
there's always like that local famous
guy that dresses with really loud
clothes they had that going
on
um it was yeah it was definitely fun and
there was a few people that look like
have you seen those things my daughter
watches them sometimes you know you know
those creepy like YouTube families they
either all sing together or they all you
know do like Ninja Warrior stuff and
they're just so [__] like perfect
that you're just sitting there thinking
like in 10 years these kids are going to
tell the true
story you know I didn't have a childhood
he was you know the Joe Jackson [__] he
was [__] overbearing speaking of that
shout out to the [__] Osman family
Donnie Marie and all of them like there
was never any sort of like uh
overbearing parent it seemed making them
at least they didn't say anything cuz it
always seemed like with those
families you know where they were like
you know we're just a family that likes
to sing together and you know they have
all these [__] like albums come out
usually about 10 15 years after then
they make like the Lifetime movie about
like what really happened and people
getting locked into [__] closets and
[__] with purple crayons or
whatnot um if you want to see something
great watch the Osman with
share covering
um Stevie wers
Superstition it's actually in a lot of
ways the history of this country where
it's like somebody not white did
something
then white people do it and
then the person that did it kind of
Fades
away initially I know it wasn't like
that everybody knows Stevie want to did
it but there's just something funny
about that very
superstitious it's such a [__] badass
song it actually still not that bad when
the osman's and uh share do it it still
sound like the music still sounds
[__] good all right what am I doing
here getting into the weeds here Christ
I'm off the [__] road here why does
my [__] screen keep shutting off oh I
know why I got it on the save I got it
on save
mode every two goddamn minutes
um I saw a dog I wanted to adopt when I
was in New York and Nia said the same
thing it's just cute little look like a
Bull Terrier with like pitbull mix or
something like that you know I got to
tell you these [__] pitbulls for as
much as they try to outlaw them they're
out there [__] you know
they're out there banging a lot of
dogs um everything seems to be Mi mixed
with like a pitbull at least when it
comes to like a rescue and the person
was walking it and it and it had like a
little sweater on and it said rescue
me and uh I saw I was thinking oh man I
would [__] rescue that dog and then
Nia immediately said that she goes if we
lived in New York we'd own that dog
right now I was like you felt that too
she goes yep she goes that's how I am
with dogs I just just look at him and I
know immediately I was like yep um I
also ran out I ran out of underwears and
socks the night I had to go to the
UFC so I Google like closest underwear
right Siri and they lead me to this
[__] place cuz we were staying down
at low E side I ended up down in
SoHo and you know you know those those
shops that have
like you walk in they have like 10
pieces it's not like walking into the
gap where they're trying to clothe half
the [__] world these things just have
pieces you know people walk out and they
have like you know one little bag I was
in that part of town and so I show up to
the underwear place the address and
they're not there anymore so now I'm
down there with like this is where like
all the [__] fashioned people are so
I'm walking in these places like you
sell underwear and socks they're like no
no we don't we only
sell outfits right
and oh my God the [__] Tourette's
that I had the [__] Tourette's
because when I walked in and like I had
a really small window too to be able to
get back to the hotel and make it for
the uh the dinner and then the ride to
the UFC and I'm [__] I I struck out
in like the fourth straight place and
I'd be like do you know any place around
here that sells underwear and socks
they're like um if you go all the way
back up to Hon the Adidas
store like [__] so I start walking out
and I'm [__] cursing my brains out
walking up the street and
uh I end up seeing this [__]
dog like coming down the street with its
owner and it has like shoes on and that
actually made me laugh it's like that
dog has shoes and I can't find underwear
and socks underwears underwear and socks
so um ended up going into
uh what did I go into Polo I'm like
they'll have that there so I went in
there and I just I was like where's your
underwear they're like right here I'm
like I'll take those you eat some socks
yes they're like how are how are these
I'm like good and then I left and then
Nia told me she didn't like the
[Music]
underwear she goes it's too big I go no
it isn't it's so large it fits she goes
no it's too like saggy I go I didn't
want the grape Smuggler one she goes H
she goes those are more flattering I'm
like what would I make it to walk down
the street like a [__] underwear
model I like the baggier
underwear sitting there [__] putting
my nuts in a vice like why would I want
to do that I I don't know but she gave
me [__] so now I'm like for half a
second I was questioning the underwear
and then I was just like no [__] that
I'm keeping these you
know I like Ralph
Lauren poor
guy Jewish guy trying to [__] be the
marbor man knowing that he wouldn't be
accepted in Most states he still went
for it you know another self-made man
you ever watch his uh his
documentary that's what I do instead of
reading I just [__] watch
documentaries and what I loved about
Ralph Lauren was that he he liked like
Ferraris and stuff and would take stuff
from that and put it into his clothes
because other than that then it's just
about Clos and then on board [__] list
but it was a nice one of those overlap
ones that you know you can watch with
your y wife right all right dude I'm
done babbling here
indochino speaking of
Suits it's the people that are putting
Ralph Lauren out of business it's
indochino you know no matter what's in
your closet that's a loaded thing right
there skeletons sexuality indochino
makes it easy to keep your wardrobe
fresh with looks made just for you from
Suits and shirts to outter wear and more
and for limited time you can shop Indo
Chino's best prices of the Year during
the their Black Friday event you know
what's great you can shop online so you
don't have to get [__]
trampled sorry had a weird hiccup there
trampled you won't get
trampled down at the
Walmart uh don't wait book your
appointment now with sales starting in
store and online November 6 you be funny
if you just had to go to Walmart and you
forgot it was black Black Friday you
know everybody there to get the last
Atari you know for [__] six bucks and
you're standing there you know cuz you
want some [__] Cheetos you're like
man this is [__] intense what's going
[Music]
on you're like oh [__] is this Black
Friday and you just get trampled cuz you
wanted some Mountain Dew uh Made For You
Suits start at just
$349 and premium shirts start at just
$49 get more looks for Le with Indo
Chino unbelievable bundles two suits
starting at 749 and five shirts for
$249 give yourself countless
customizable options with new Styles and
fabrics added throughout the sale yeah
go watch Steve Harvey's video on suits
how you make three suits and you turn
them into seven it's like when Jesus
kept pulling the fish out of the basket
he's doing that with habiter every suit
is made to your exact measurements and
you can customize every detail create a
suit that fits you and your style
perfectly with endless customization
options so you get the exact look you
want blazes pants skirts and more
designed and made for you hundreds of
highquality fabrics to choose from
quality European wools linen and cotton
in a wide range of colors and patterns
submit your measurements online or work
with one of Indo Chino's expert style gu
guides to create an outfit made just for
you refresh your wardrobe with the best
prices of the Year during indochino
Black Friday event secure secure your
new your appointment now with sales
starting in store and online November 6
at
indochino.com that's i n d o
c.com all
right okay there's the reads for the
week all right got those out of the way
let's let's read the
[__] the questions here um down
under hey you bald
freckled hey you bald freckled nothing
else after it are you avoiding the
Australian son because of your condition
you know Ginger pale legs too thin to
fight a kangaroo or what I'm waiting
Perth is waiting the sun is waiting we
want another sunburned ginger on our
beach you can never have enough pink
balding men love your podcast mate go
[__] yourself though
um I know I haven't been I haven't been
there in a long time you know during the
pandemic I did one of those
um those things that all all
entertainers thought were going to take
over where they basically you
know you go to a place in like the
valley that's what I did I went to a PL
someone house in the valley I stood
there and they're like dude like 20,000
people are going to [__] order this
thing and there isn't there's like 400
people just order it cuz like
entertainers thought like you know what
would be [__] great is if rather than
having to go on tour you know I could
just do one show for the whole [__]
world and then get paid like you just
toured the world and you only had to do
one set
that's what people were talking about
and I was sitting there going like that
ain't going to [__]
work that's not going to it's not the
same thing it's not the same thing as
going there and seeing it I can tell you
that watching the UFC on
TV is [__] amazing you have your
friends over and all of that [__] it's
[__] great but being
there was was I I can't explain it it
was just
[__] I don't even know why it was so
much better like I actually felt I
could see what was going to happen in
the fight or understand it better than
you know I guess when you watch it at
home you got Joe to break the whole
[__] thing down but um just stuff I
never noticed I don't know it's kind of
like the same thing if you go watch go
to a football game live you can actually
look at the defense rather than just
seeing like the lines and the
quarterback you know because they got
that that angle where you
know I I guess if they're up on the line
and they're showing you the look you can
kind of guess what it is but I'm not
good at that stuff and I like you know
looking at the the different packages or
whatever the [__] they have and
hopefully somebody near you understands
the game more than you and you can like
watch that or like watch like a matchup
or something like that um you know gives
you like the options or whatever so
getting back to that like as funny as a
comedian's going to be on TV there's
it's never going to be funnier than
actually seeing the person live and I
feel like music too you know as amazing
as all of these musicians are and
everything there's just nothing like
being there in the energy of the crowd
that's is what sucks about the phones
though you know people on their phones
and stuff so I like those ones where you
go there and they make you put your
phone away and [__]
um cuz that [__] sphere thing in
Vegas Jesus
Christ every [__] video was about
what was floating on the ceiling nothing
was is about the band oh my God look at
that dude what the [__] holy [__] just
sitting there filming
[__] I kind of feel like that's a little
too much you know if I want to see [__]
I'll just take mushrooms I don't need a
sphere you don't have to [__] spend
all your
money earn the hallucination you know do
some
psychedelics all right sorry I probably
shouldn't say that okay Grandma Grandpa
doing pull-ups dear Billy biceps I
recently heard what you're doing uh that
that you're doing pull-ups now uh I'm
back to doing pull-ups I've done
pull-ups my entire adult life until I
messed up my shoulders he said what
doing push-ups isn't enough for you
anymore I know the rotator cuff yada
yada anyway get this you said that you
want to be able to do 10 pull-ups at the
age of 70 I think you'd manage a little
bit more and here's why my grandfather
did 30 yeah but some people I don't know
what it is they just built Jim Norton
can do a thousand [__] pull-ups um
I'm not one of those people I got to
[__] work for every one of them my
grandfather like the first time I ever
tried to do a [__] pull-up was they
used to have this thing the president's
physical fitness
test this is before body shaming you
know and you had to be able to do 10
pull-ups like when I started to do a
pull up like I felt like I was paralyzed
like I wasn't even born with those
muscles and I somehow like
like willed myself to do
three and I never forgot that I was just
like I just felt like such and everybody
was watching I felt like such a [__]
[__] cuz I could do you know like 10 15
pull-ups but I mean chinups but the
pull-ups like I I I couldn't even do
them so from that moment on I've had a
chin up bar my entire life you know I
had in my parents' basement in like two
or three different houses you know we
moved around a lot and then every
apartment I ever had I had a p pullup
bar um in the door
jam somewhere in the
apartment um usually the bathroom cuz I
had like studio so it's not like I had
like a I wasn't going to stick it in
like the [__] obviously unless the
door Swang out to go inside anyway I'm
babbling here so um your grandfather did
30 I bet your grandfather was always
good at him uh clean pull-ups fully
extended arms to Shin above the Y at
above the bar at age of
90 that's
90 damn Prussian discipline yeah and
that person never stopped doing them and
had like perfect form that's awesome I
can't even do that many pull-ups in my
mid-30s and I'm quite athletic so he was
and is an absolute inspiration for me
for a few months now I've started
training pull-ups and I started out with
a maximum of eight a few weeks in I
already was up to 10 and now I'm doing
between 12 and 14 yeah I got up to seven
before I left they weren't good ones
though uh depending on the day if I
slept all right ate enough Etc I only
started this because of my grandfather
and hoped to be able to continue
training until I'm old uh my grandfather
also started out with Jujitsu at age the
age of 70 10 years later he had his
black belt and kept progressing to third
degree d a n triple black belt basically
in in his early 90s if that isn't an
inspiration I don't know what is yeah
that's why he's still living he has a
reason to get up in the morning stay
disciplined and keep at it you Ginger
[__] I don't know why I just you guys
insult me I don't I just I I always feel
the love it just cracks me up and it's
just something funny that you give
somebody in inspiration and then trash
him after you know stay disciplined and
keep at it and raise your B to say thank
you it's you Ginger
[__] anyway other than that I love your
sense of humor you always bring a smile
to my face even during my dark times uh
greetings from the old world and of
course greeting to your YF uh go Fu
yourself all right that's awesome all
right well
I'm going to get back on it but I'm also
like trying not to push myself because I
don't want to get reinjured
again like I could I can do seven shitty
ones or four good ones so I'm like let's
just go back to doing good ones I'm
going to I got four good
ones all right cashless Society oh here
we go here we go here we go into the
[__] weeds here hey Bill fan from
Australia here have you happen to hear
about countries going I never asked
answered that
guy when am I going back to Australia I
I don't know man my kids have to get
older cuz I got to bring
them I just there's just something about
being that far
away and I don't know I did do Europe
Europe just you know it's in the same
[__] hemisphere
though that's like literally like you're
like a day ahead but I I [__] love
Australia and I also loved Perth and I
went there on Australia day and it was
just a bunch of animals and like what
looked like El Caminos driving around
[__] shitfaced and I'm like this
reminds me of
Massachusetts um and the most beautiful
beaches in the
world you know I've never been to South
America or
um Africa but as far as what I've seen
I've never seen more beautiful beaches
then in Australia and I am terrified of
the [__]
ocean and I I I felt compelled to go
into the
ocean um thank God it was freezing cold
out so I didn't but it
was it was unbelievable they're just
where the I think it was in Melbourne
and I was just just sat there just
staring at it was kind of rough Seas too
so that was another thing just seeing
the [__] power of it um
anyway cashless societ
hey Bill from Australia here have you
happened to hear about countries going
cashless um I don't remember anyone here
voting on the matter and yet it seems to
be happening anyway well that's like AI
nobody wants that [__] that's that's for
the rich people uh there was recently an
outrage with the company that controls
transfers called Optus that prevented
millions of people from completing
transactions even though everyone can
see how this will cause huge problems in
the future to not allow people to use
cash experts are saying there is no
turning
back yeah you don't have you don't have
a choice in any of this we're this
everything that you're worried about is
going to happen until there's some
massive Revolution and then but then
what's going to happen is just another
sociopath is going to get into into
Power um
I saw people going nuts the other night
for this
sociopath [__] sociopath and I'm like
this guy is
robbing literally everybody in here you
know it's just it's just how people are
they buy you buy into a [__]
ideology in this country it's it's like
I don't
know I think they're all in bed
together I think at the end of the day
when they when Fox News and CNN when
they shut off I think they all go out
drinking together I think it's I think
it's like wrestling I think it's just a
big [__] show I don't buy any of it I
think the politicians do the same thing
and then they all [__] go to some
giant [__] circle jerk or some [__] I
don't know what the [__] they do anyways
uh changes in history have nothing to do
with what people want and they just come
out of nowhere here's an article from
MSN about it um well it wasn't link
I don't have the link I you know what
dude and I honestly don't even want to
read
it um they're going to say that the
Casual Society is for convenience and
what it really is is it's an
ability if they want to get you to limit
your ability to move and run away
because they will just freeze everything
they'll freeze your credit cards and now
you can't get to any cash and nobody
accepts cash or believes in it anymore
you're [__] so that can get you on an
individual level and more importantly I
it takes away dramatically takes away
the ability to
revolt
against uh an
oppressor because you need money to buy
your illegal guns and all of that
because God knows it's going to have to
be done in a violent way but the thing
about it is is the human [__]
brain okay with determination will
always figure out away we'll always
figure out away I still remember this
time this guy was in jail and he was
building a [__] hand glider out of
dental floss and bed sheets and all that
now I'm not saying it didn't work but
like he had the [__]
time and he was you
know I mean when you look at dental
floss what you see I see dental floss I
don't see something to tie to PCP pipe
whatever the [__] he had and bed sheets
and that this could potentially help me
fly but when the need is created
so I just don't think that they're going
to be able to
um they're not going to be able to stop
us the big [__] thing is if if is if
they keep us pitted against one
another which is why why I try to stay
out of like
uh you know all of this all of that
politics [__] all of that that all of
that crap this 24-hour news networks I
stay out of that [__] and I try to act
as an individual and I try to act
um just try to be nice to people you
know and try to help people out if you
can I think if you're just doing
that
um I don't know that's that's what I'm
hanging on to because everything else
gets too big and gets too
[__]
um
overwhelming like what is amazing is is
I think the hardest [__] human
emotion is
empathy and um and it's funny we just
let's let's just act like there really
is only two ways to look at things
conservative and and
liberal what's funny okay the
conservative
stereotypically speaking do not have
empathy for
anything you know they think they do but
they don't right and then you got
liberals who think that they're
empathetic but they
actually you know they're too busy
congratulating themselves like what is
that douchy thing now I'm an empath I'm
an empath and they literally make like
having
empathy like this thing that you're now
supposed to help them with like oh my
God that must be so hard God you care so
much like what in the [__] is that I'm
an
empath that's right up there when they
said Donald Trump you don't seem that
humble and then he just went like
actually I'm one of the greatest uh you
know I'm one of the most humblest people
you ever going to meet I don't think you
can even comprehend comprehend how
humble I am and you're sitting there
looking like dude you're doing a bit
right and he's dead [__] serious
liberals with that I'm an empath you
know like things like that are hard for
me because I'm an EMP you're not an
empath you're completely
self-involved you're totally
self-involved you're so [__]
self-involved you're actually using one
of the most beautiful emotions a human
being can have empathy and you're
turning it in into this this [__]
self- congratulatory thing H here has
some [__] dating advice for
you all right if you meet
somebody and they describe themselves as
a [__] empath run out of the
room just get out of the [__] room
that is a totally self-involved [__]
[__] that is never going to admit when
they're
wrong um all
right oh God I hate everybody all right
lead Zeppelin
4 let's see if I can still name all the
tracks starts with black
dog then it's rock and roll then it's
going to
California then
it's uh Stairway to
Heaven then is it Misty Mountain
Hop then four
sticks then something else and then When
the Levy Breaks I can't remember
I don't I don't [__] know [__]
anymore right dear Billy music brain
58-year-old fat [__] from Germany here
how's it going guten tug um I recently
read a story about Led Zeppelin that
might interest you a lot of people
predicted professional suicide for Leed
Zeppelin with a decision that also set
alarm bells ringing at their record
company Atlantic Records in
1971 the new album was not to have a
title and Leed Zeppelin name Leed
Zeppelin's name was not to appear on the
cover instead there was a strange
picture of an old man carrying a load of
hazelnut rods the band wanted to prove
to journalist who had strongly
criticized the previous album that their
records sold even without a reference to
the authors and they were
right oh yeah they used to get a ton of
[__] from critics hey guess who El gets
a ton of [__] I always do they always
[__] trash me um you know critics
trash well the big the big Publications
liked old dads but we we got a lot of
[__] from people and uh but then the
people liked it you know what's funny is
the amount of people that can't can't
even remember the name of the movie Old
dads I was in uh Hollywood Florida this
elderly couple go to take a picture with
me and the woman goes she goes uh I
loved your movie old
[Music]
guys when I was in Brooklyn somebody
said I love your movie Bad
dads someone else called it old
people and I just [__] and then like
Nia's always there so Nia is just
cracking up
laughing and teasing the [__] out of me
and I'm like I don't give a [__] you
know I get why they can't remember it
there's
like they're like scrolling through
Netflix all of those [__] movies it's
like you know you hit the jackpot if
they they select your thing there so
anyway
um so they got a ton of [__] uh and they
were right Led Zeppelin 4 as the album
is UN let's up on four as the album is
unofficially called because it is the
band's fourth record even became their
most successful release selling 37
million units uh said cover of the
classic album has become an icon of
music and as a huge fan of Leed zeppin
of course you know it a lecturer at the
University of West England has now
managed to unravel The Mystery of
the enigmatic enigmatic image while
preparing an
exhibition for the Wiltshire
Museum oh dude this is like right up my
alley musical trivia I love this [__] he
found the original picture by chance is
is in an album that presented around a
100 early
photographs mostly houses Street Scenes
and some portraits of Farm Workers he
investigated further and discovered that
the man was most likely the
roofer lot long or lot longer who lived
in the village of Meir from
1823 to
1893 next year an exhibition at the
wilsh wilsh the Wiltshire Museum will
commemorate those times the photo that
ended up on the the lead zeppin cover
will also be on
display oh man I got to see that perhaps
you'll be performing in England again in
the future and fancy a trip to to the
southwest of England to see a bit of
rock history I would 100% do that there
are beautiful cities like bath or
Bristol impressive Landscapes and last
but not least
Stonehenge which is only a few miles
away from Wilshire Museum plus the
people have an incredibly nice they are
incredibly nice I have experienced this
myself time and time again during
numerous visits of course I don't know
if the coffee there meets your standards
I don't give a [__] because England is
obviously tea territory well hey you
know I would definitely drink the
[__] tea then uh keep up the great
work all the best to you and your family
and go [__] your myself I also really
like an English
breakfast you know bangers and mash
whatever the [__] they call
them the little sausages and the eggs I
like that I like a German breakfast
where they have the hardboiled egg in
that thing like it's a [__]
trophy
um I actually you know it's I'm trying
to think of all the different breakfasts
I've
had going throughout the world everybody
has like a weird take on it I mean
obviously partial
to the American
breakfast you know which is just all
about shoving as much [__] [__] down
your throat as you possibly
can you know the Grand Slam
breakfast who would have a problem with
that I mean the Grand Slam breakfast I
mean around the world okay we're talking
two eggs however you want
them two sausage two bacon and a short
stack of pancakes you
know glass of orange juice and some
water that's the classic Grand Slam
[__] breakfast all right not saying
that we we like in this thing nobody
does that at home that's something you
go out you go out to [__] Denny's or
uh the International House of Pancakes
or a [__] greasy spoon or some [__]
you do that but you never do that at
home you know what I mean it's it's too
much [__] work you get the batter G
and I got to get the eggs going and as
I'm thinking this I'm like I'm going to
[__] do this I'm going to make a
grand slam breakfast I'm going to do it
one of these
days what you say what's what's a good
is is there International House of
Pancake Day where you just go out who
who does the Grand Slam is it
Denny's I always like IHOP better than
Denny's and it's just the colors I just
like blue and that blue roof was
peaceful to me and for some reason I
thought that their sticky tables were A
Cut Above Denny's you know
I would say the IHOP is a little sweeter
and I would say Denny's is a little more
Savory I just felt there's a lot more
salt coming from Denny's side but that
might just be like psychological because
of the
colors you know
um but
anyway I don't know what to do with
myself
now I got one more [__] gig and I'm G
to go to that F1 race it's going to be
fantastic I also have a movie coming out
um that I did a voice on called Leo that
stars the one and only Adam Sandler so
that's going to be coming out I know
there's a Premiere this weekend that
we're
doing so
um I'm going to get I got to promote
that the strike is over feels weird it
feels weird talking about projects so
can I talk about old dads if you guys
have any questions now about old dads
about where we shot things about making
it and all that cuz I tell you that is
the most work I've ever done in my life
and here's another thing too people keep
saying he wrote it directed it I
co-wrote
it I co-wrote it with Ben tishler all
right and Ben tishler is the reason why
that movie got [__] made because it
never would have got written without him
cuz I told him the idea that I had it
just came off for like one day like I
was
um I was dropping my my daughter off at
school or something like that and they
got on the jungle gym I was like are you
on the jungle gym and she's like Dad
it's called D structure it was just
every singles every single thing I
said was like wrong and then I had to
think like I have not been in [__]
preschool in 50 years like all of this
[__] has changed and
um it just gave me like this little bit
of an idea and I just mentioned it to
Ben and he was like dude we should write
that
and he just kept showing up every day to
write it so I mean I didn't have the
discipline to do it I've had a bunch of
ideas for
um movies and stuff
and I've just never done them and I
finally understood that I needed
somebody with the discipline to do it
and uh I've been working with
Ben I've I've been working with Ben
since like 2005 2006 I forget how we
came together but we somehow the NFL
wanted some sort of
um wanted some sort of like funny
commercial to promote the league and
through that I got hired I think it an
audition and then they hired Ben to
direct it and then we got to know each
other and then that was it and of course
what we did we thought was
hilarious and they were like no no no no
you're making fun of the fans we had two
[__] funny
ideas the first
one was
um I get I get why they didn't use it
like we were kind of making fun of you
know
like we went to a Raiders game this is
when they were playing in Oakland and we
went there and we would go up to the
people that were all dressed crazy and
we would ask them about going to the
Raiders game they'd be all [__] amped
up and everything and then gradually I
would start asking
questions about like you know politics
and global warming and then they would
just totally
change their their tone and then they
had this ridiculous outfit on and they
you know going you know dress like Darth
Vader or something and just being like
you know well I mean I think that's more
of a federal issue and then they would
just be talking about that and then the
final question was are you currently in
a
relationship so they were like that
one's too mean so we so that one struck
up and then years later I was at this
sports bar big wangs on
Kanga uh it doesn't exist anymore I
don't think I think it it moved to
Downtown
LA and the Patriots are playing the
Ravens and there was this Ravens fan
that was so [__]
obnoxious I wanted to [__] kill him
and it was it was that playoff game
where their first run from scrimmage
where they just won and this guy was
going like like yelling in our faces and
stuff um to this day I don't know why he
wasn't thrown out of the bar but
like he was bigger than me and could
kick the [__] out of me and he was
upsetting me so much I was thinking like
yeah but I get that first one in then I
just Turtle he'd probably get you know
two punches and a couple kicks and then
the bouncers would break it up and maybe
it' be worth it or whatever and I just
like it's like Bill it's not worth it
okay I was [__] I was in my 40s but
this guy made me so [__] mad and my
team
lost um and he was a mouth breathing
[__] [__] that I was like I have to
get something out of this so then we
wrote an ad campaign for Direct
TV the NFL
package and basically what it
was was
um how the [__] did it go it was a
guy sitting in a sports bar trying to
watch his team play this is like you
know 10 years ago so I know everybody
can now watch the game on your phone you
couldn't do this back then so basically
the G the the the bit was you know I was
going to dress like you know [__]
nerd right glasses and all of this [__]
and I was just sitting there trying to
watch my team and everyone's just
screaming yelling all day you know ah
screaming and spilling drinks on you and
you can't see it you can't hear it and
um just getting pushed around the room
and all of that spun around you know a
lot of sight
gags and then in the end it was going to
be you know I just looked totally
frazzled like I'm not having a good time
and then the end of the commercial I'm
sitting at
home with Direct
TV and I just turn on the game and I'm
just sitting there totally relaxed and
it
said uh the NFL package on Direct TV and
then you you just the guy was yelling in
my face Drives By in the car with his
head out the window like Ace Ventura on
his way to the sports bar just
goes he and it says
yeah yeah now that you know the psych it
would go like this Direct TV the NFL
package
yeah and then it's it pays for itself
something like that and it was him being
at home you get the point um so anyway
we've been doing [__] like that forever
I think we ended up doing something for
the NHL I can't remember I just remember
shooting these things with like Billy
Gardell before he was uh on uh Mike and
Molly
just a long [__] time ago so anyways
the point is I've
known um Ben forever uh Ben tishler and
uh so when people say I wrote the thing
say that I co-wrote it so anyway if you
guys do have any questions I'm so
[__] excited that I can finally
[__] talk about it and all the great
actors that were in it and uh all the
people that helped me with it cuz I had
a ton of [__] help but I I do want to
take the time to say thank you to all
you guys
the movie was number one the number one
movie streamed on Netflix globally for
two weekends in a row the third week it
was still in the top five and the fourth
week was still in the top 10 so it's
been a huge huge hit and uh if you guys
didn't watch it it wouldn't be so thank
you very much I really appreciate it all
right so that's it that is the uh Monday
Morning
podcast um go [__] yourselves and thank
you thank you to everybody that came out
to my shows I had I had such a great
time I had such a great time at
MSG you know doing my show thank you to
Dana White hooking us up with the
tickets uh my wife and I have always
wanted to go to one of those things it
was
fantastic and uh thank you to that
person that made me that um egg cream
whatever the [__] you call it I am
absolutely sold on that and that's
something that I will only get in New
York City at that place I got something
else some old other old man thing to do
here all right that's it enjoy your
weekend no I'll check in on you Thursday
that's what I'm supposed to say all
right